Gracias por estar con nosotros y
cuéntenos cómo fueron esos meses bajo
encierro
efectivamente las condiciones en las que
la mayor parte del tiempo permanecimos
fueron condiciones
de encarcelamiento que lesionan la
esencia de la humanidad de las personas
la incomunicación total o parcial el
aislamiento
la poca información el el nulo acceso a
información sobre lo que está pasando
fuera lo que pasa con tu familia la
imposibilidad de ver a tus seres
queridos frecuentemente hemos pasado por
por tantas cosas como por ejemplo el
hecho de que nunca se aprobó que se nos
permitiera leer nunca se nos permitió
tener acceso a algo tan elemental para
para muchos de nosotros como una Biblia
por ejemplo o un lápiz o un papel para
poder escribir nunca hubo Más allá de
aquellas cosas básicas pero aquellas
cosas que te hacen humano que te hacen
compartir con los demás que te hacen
sobrellevar este momento esas cosas no
no fueron permitidas y cada momento el
encierro personas que pasaron encerrados
en celdas de castigo por casi más de un
año o más de un año Como medardo mairena
por ejemplo ya el barajón otros presos
políticos como yo que también han sido
Ya liberados ellos pasaron condiciones
duras realmente duras como otros casos
que que podría mencionar pero que son
ejemplos que te demuestran la dureza de
las condiciones carcelarias arbitrarias
e ilegales a las cuales son sometidos
los opositores en Nicaragua y adicional
a estas duras cohibiciones de las que
usted habla usted presenció o vivió un
momento muy difícil porque su mamá
falleció cuando usted estaba en la
cárcel y muchos organismos de Derechos
Humanos pedían le pedían al gobierno que
le permitieran ir al entierro cuéntanos
Qué pasó
bueno efectivamente uno de los momentos
más difíciles probablemente de mi vida
fue el fallecimiento de mi mamá y
realmente puedo decir que no solo no me
permitieron ir a sentirlos no solo no me
permitieron saber que ella estaba
pasando su último momento sino que
tampoco pude conocer que había fallecido
en el momento exacto de su fallecimiento
solo pude saberlo casi un mes después un
mes después de que ya había fallecido
después de que habían sido sus funerales
cuando se nos permitió una una visita
con nuestra familia después de seis
semanas o mes y medio de de cada visita
y eso fue un momento difícil un momento
difícil porque sé que mi mamá sufrió
mucho demandando la libertad No solo mía
sino la libertad de todos los
prisioneros políticos en Nicaragua yo
creo que ese sufrimiento no será en vano
y espero y comprometido seriamente
Porque ninguna madre más en Nicaragua
tenga que ver a su hijo ser llevado
falsamente a un tribunal o a la cárcel
por razones políticas
lamento mucho lo que usted vivió
cuéntenos Cómo se enteraron que ustedes
serían liberados y enviados a otro país
en este caso Estados Unidos
bueno el proceso de liberación al cual
fuimos sometidos fue un proceso del cual
no teníamos Conocimiento es decir Fue un
proceso
repentino Por así decirlo en ningún
momento se nos informó que íbamos a
hacer liberado o que íbamos a hacer
llevados a otro lugar hasta que ya
estábamos a las puertas de
la al pie de las escaleras del avión que
no llevo fuera de nuestro país no
Simplemente nos dijeron
cámbiense la ropa Estos son este sus
mudadas
cámbiense y luego nos montaron en
autobuses que entonces que cuyo destino
no sabíamos cuál era y había muchas
especulaciones Pues cuál podría ser
nuestro destino en esos momentos muchas
suposiciones sin embargo todo esto
culminó con el proceso que nos llevó
fuera de Nicaragua que nos llevó rumbo a
Estados Unidos y que también culminó con
una arbitrariedad legal que se denominó
como la cancelación de la nacionalidad
nicaragüense para todos los que hemos
sido presos políticos en Nicaragua una
cosa que es Absurda los nicaragüenses y
los presos políticos nicaragüenses los
exiliados y los opositores seremos
nicaragüenses donde quiera que estemos y
vamos a Nicaragua en nuestro corazón
amamos nuestra Patria y pronto vamos a
regresar a ella
bueno Y como nicaragüenses y como
opositores como interpretan esta acción
de Daniel Ortega de enviarlos a otro
país y también inhabilitarlos para
acceder a cargos públicos de por vida
Bueno yo creo que detrás de esta acción
se esconde la profunda derrota una
derrota más de la dictadura que tuvo que
ceder ante la presión de todos los
nicaragüenses que demandaban la libertad
inmediata de todos los prisioneros
políticos de todos los perreos de
conciencia que estaban siendo
injustamente encarcelados enjuiciados y
condenados y creo que el hecho de que
Ortega haya tenido que ceder en la
liberación de personas a las cuales en
horas previas se les habían dado
sentencias absurdas de 10 años 13 años
de que se le habían cancelado
ciertos derechos y que los haya tenido
que liberar inmediatamente es una
profunda derrota porque no se puede
traducir de otra forma y sobre todo yo
espero y estoy
consciente de que Nicaragua necesita una
salida una medida así no es la solución
que Nicaragua no es la única solución
que nicaragüense necesita los presos
políticos son solamente uno de los
síntomas del profundo problema que
encierra Nicaragua bajo la dictadura de
Daniel Ortega este problema esencial Es
la falta de democracia la falta de
libertades la falta de estabilidad en el
país que se traduce en otras cosas como
El Éxodo masivo en nicaragüense que
hemos visto jóvenes del campo abandonar
las fincas las ciudades abandonar las
los centros de producción agrícola del
país porque no creen ya que tienen un
futuro en este país creo que Nicaragua
va a necesitar un profundo proceso de
diálogos Genuino que pase por abrir las
puertas de Nicaragua a la democracia y a
la libertad de manera definitiva